Bah, tu t'es encore fais larguer?
Euh papa s'te plaît là je suis crevée,
je peux poser mes affaires et genre on en parle après? Parce que...
Chérie...
Ah, t'as trouvé mon clap...
Tu ne sais pas dans quoi tu t'embarques, jeune fille.
Ceux qui ont joué à ce jeu en connaissent les dangers...
Non mais sérieux, déconne-pas avec ça, vraiment.
Romain?
Tu le penses vraiment?
Ok... Qu'est-ce que je fous là?
Pardon?!
Pour ne pas avoir rappelé ma fille et ne jamais la prévenir quand tu as une heure de retard, la condamnation est la mort...
Non, non, non....
Par décapitation !
Non, non, je m'excuse, je suis désolé. Non vraiment, vous allez pas faire ça?
Déconnez-pas ! Déconnez... Non...
Et mais t'es complètement malade, on a dit que c'était terminé, donc laisse-moi tranquille maintenant.
Maman disait toujours...
"La vie c'est comme une boîte de chocolat."
Non mais en fait laisse-tomber t'as l'air con, j'te préférais avant.
Attends, attends, tu fais quoi avec ce truc là?
Montre-moi ce ce que tu me fais.
Montre ! Montre ! Montre !
Arrête !
Vous ne passerez pas !
Ou alors enlève tes chaussures au moins, parce que je viens de nettoyer.
Oui alors justement, en parlant de nettoyage, parlons-en.
Parce que votre fille là, hein !
Bah alors, t'as plus rien à dire?
Non, parce que j'entends rien là.
Façon, personne peut te blairer !
Ah ouais?!
Toi, moi, n'importe qui...
Personne ne frappe aussi fort que la vie.
Merde, j'avais oublié qu'en VF c'était vraiment pas top.
Ouais...
Chérie, si tu pouvais me laisser hors de tes histoires, ce serait cool.
Salut Romain.
Mais de toute façon, je me suis toujours emmerdée avec toi.
Dommage que j'ai pas trouvé ça plus tôt, j'aurai pu te rendre sexy.
Ouais... Là c'est bien.
Un super-héros juste pour moi.
I was in the neighborhood....
T'es reloue avec ton clap.
Je l'ai pas utilisé là.
Tu sais quoi? Je crois que c'est pas une bonne idée.
Hein? Mais non, attends. Attends !
On est d'accord, c'était totalement gratuit là ?
Non mais... réflexe de défense.
Vas-y, tu peux rentrer chez toi si tu veux.
Mais non, on va pas s'arrêter maintenant.
Laisse-moi voir ce truc.
Comment ça se fait qu'il y a que toi qui peut l'utiliser?
J'crois que c'est parce qu'il y a mon nom qu'est marqué.
Attends, j'me permets...
Voilà, comme ça on va pouvoir s'amuser à deux.
Ça te dirait un film de super-héros?
J'ai une meilleure idée.
Bah on pourra pas dire qu'on a pas profité de la vie au moins.
Oh c'est pas fini.
Attends, j'ai une idée.
Une idée, tu vas voir.